Soldier: Pull out, Graham! Pull!
Pull!
[splashes]
Remi Adeleke: Yeah, it's
not that easy. [laughs]
What's up? My name is Remi Adeleke.
I spent 13 years in the military
with the majority of that time
spent in special
operations as a Navy SEAL.
And today I'm gonna be breaking down
some iconic Navy SEAL movies and TV shows.
[helicopter roaring]
Soldier: Everyone good to go?
All: Good to go.
Remi: Yeah, I've never seen
any devices like that. [laughs]
We're called SEALs.
SEAL is actually a
acronym, sea, air, land.
A lot of people don't know that.
So it's typical for us
to work in the water.
I've jumped out of a plane
into the water before.
I've jumped out of a helicopter
In the scene, they're jumping,
not only are they jumping out,
but they're pushing vehicles,
underwater vehicles into the water.
Now, those type of vehicles,
I've never seen in my life. [laughs]
There are vehicles that
we do use called SDVs.
It stands for SEAL delivery vehicles.
Goodspeed: Move in! Good to go.
Remi: There are times when,
if somebody has a unique specialization
but they're not a SEAL,
they will go on a mission,
and they will be embedded
within the SEAL platoon.
However, they're not gonna be
at the front of the train.
They're not gonna be the first
one in the door. [laughs]
That's for sure.
And they're gonna be
somewhere in the middle,
somewhere protected and
somewhere where they can't
hurt the other guys within the platoon.
"The Rock" inspired me.
That was the first time I
was exposed to Navy SEALs.
I had never heard of Navy SEALs before,
and I went to go watch the film.
And when I saw these guys,
that really intrigued me.
And then when we got to the scene where
they actually sacrifice
themselves to save other people,
that's what really kind
of stuck out to me,
this idea that these
men are so close-knit,
they're skilled,
they're great at what they do,
and they're willing to put their lives
on the line for other people.
I've worked with Michael
Bay on some other films,
so gotta be careful.
I would say I would give it
a 8.5 as far as accuracy.
[yelling]
It's supposed to be boats
on heads, but they have,
they're holding it with their hands,
and we've never done that.
There's an instructor in the boat.
Nah, that's not gonna happen.
The boat is heavy as it is.
Instructor: Move it! Move it!
Remi: The bell, yep.
The bell. That's definitely real.
I know a lot of guys
who have rang that bell.
Now, these things, I'm
assuming that these are buoys.
We never did that at all.
We never pushed buoys through a,
looks like a berm obstacle course,
so I don't know what that is.
And here we have the
buoy rolling over people.
That's not happening.
I mean, that's more of a liability.
Now, this type of surf torture,
I have never seen it.
I don't know what kind of push-up that is.
[wave crashes]
It's a mental exercise.
At least for me it was.
You're laying in this freezing cold water,
you don't know how long
you're gonna be in the water,
and that's where they get
a lot of guys who quit.
That's where you do get a lot of quitters.
Me, there were multiple
times during hell week
and various evolutions
where, during surf torture,
I was either near
hypothermia or hypothermic.
As a matter of fact, during
one surf torture in hell week
my core temperature dropped
down to 88.7 degrees.
So. [laughs] And what happened after that
was the instructors took
me to BUD/S medical,
went through a rewarming drill.
I think it took about a
hour or two to rewarm me.
And then as soon as I was back
to a normal core temperature,
I went right back into hell week,
and when the instructors
asked me, they said,
"Hey, you wanna quit
or do you wanna go back
in that cold water?"
And I said, "I'll go back
in the cold water." So.
[yelling]
The instructors are trying
to put you in a situation
where you have to work together as a team
and push through the discomfort.
There's cases where, if
you're not running in sync,
the boat will bob and
bounce on a person's head
and that just causes more pain.
There's actually been guys
who have had serious neck injuries
and fractured their necks
because of the bouncing
or because somebody within
the boat was ducking boat,
which means they had their head down
while other people were
carrying the weight.
So it's a pretty serious evolution.
And the instructor in the boat, eh,
I would have to give it about a four.
Instructor: Six times three.
Hurry up, hurry up, hurry up.
Remi: What we're seeing here is a swim,
it's called wetsuit appreciation swim.
And essentially they make you
swim in freezing cold water
for a long period of
time without a wetsuit.
And it's miserable.
It's horrible.
Instructor: Andrew! Come back!
Remi: Yeah, this guy,
he's a shallow water,
shallow water blackout.
You know, he blacked out
from being on the water.
The majority of it is footage from
a Discovery Channel
documentary called "BUD/S 234."
And, interestingly, I
watched that documentary
in order to prepare for
BUD/S, 'cause, you know,
coming from the Bronx, and I
didn't have a lot of exposure
to Navy SEALs or how to
prepare for SEAL training.
As a matter of fact,
when I joined the Navy,
I couldn't swim.
Instructor: Two minutes!
You don't make it, you do it again!
Instructor: Have you been tested this hard
ever in your life?
Trainee: Never.
Remi: BUD/S is six months
broken up into three phases.
First phase, which is where they really
weed out the majority of the class.
Then there's second phase,
which is dive phase.
That's when they're
beginning to really teach you
different elements of being a SEAL.
And then third phase is, weapons, tactics,
land warfare, and demolitions.
If a person makes it
through six months of BUD/S,
then next step is SQT, SEAL
qualification training.
That's where you really get into the weeds
of what it means to be a Navy SEAL
and to do the job that we do.
And then from there you
go on to your SEAL team.
For an attrition rate,
for SEAL training, fluctuates
between 75 and 90%.
The class that I graduated
with started out with 270,
and we only graduated 29 guys.
I have to give it a 10.
I have to give it 'cause
it's the real deal.
You don't get no realer
than that. [laughs]
Jack: Listen to me. Listen.
Hey, listen up.
When you go outside
that gate, you go left.
You understand?
Rone: Yes.
Jack: The right is bad
guys. You are going left.
You get in the back way to the annex.
You got it?
Rone: I got it.
Remi: This guy who's driving
and he seems disoriented
and he's not paying attention to this,
'cause most likely he's not a SEAL.
If he was a SEAL, he
wouldn't be as confused.
[gunshots]
[shouting]
Jack: Peel it! Peel it! Peel it!
Someone cover us on the roof!
Remi: What was going on
was the guys were bounding.
And when a unit is bounding
away from a contact,
it's always important
for one or two or three,
however many guys, to be shooting
and the other part of that
team moving, you know,
we call that shoot, move or cover move.
So, in the clip, you know,
John's character said, "cover and move,"
and that's something we always do
when we're bounding from a contact.
Those are all weapons
that not only, you know,
I've carried, but I've seen
other guys in my platoon,
in my teams carry when we go
out the door on operations.
This movie, "13 Hours," is based off of
an actual event that happened in Benghazi.
The embassy was attacked and overrun.
The guys who were defending,
for the most part,
they were all guys who have
special operations backgrounds.
A few of them were Navy SEALs.
Actually, one of them, the
guy who got killed, Ty.
Ty Woods was my BUD/S instructor.
He put me through SEAL training.
Personally, I would give it a 9.5.
[helicopter roaring]
So, they're fast-roping.
I've fast-roped before.
Fast rope, it's a easy way
to insert into a situation.
Pilot: Continue, you're clear.
Remi: This guy right here,
he's an intelligence guy.
He's a SEAL, but he's
also an intelligence guy.
We call it HUMINT, which
is human intelligence,
and that's what I did in the SEAL teams.
Not only are they covering down on doors
as one guy's, as the point
man is moving forward,
but they're covering down on windows.
So, everything is a threat
when you're on operation,
especially, you know, on a ship like this,
or a house, you know, closets,
open doors,
windows,
hidden spaces.
Soldier: Clear. Bridge secure.
Remi: When one guy says clear,
clear is just, that's something we say
when the room is clear.
That doesn't mean that
nobody's in the room.
That means that the room is clear.
[boat engine roaring]
The SOC boats that you saw in the clip,
they're really high speed.
They're operated by a special
operations unit called SWCC.
SWCC stands for special
warfare combat-craft crewman.
On the rivers and any
operation along the water,
they help insert SEALs and
extract SEALs from targets.
They used real Navy SEALs
and real SWCC operators
as the main actors,
so I would give it a 9.5.
The 0.5 that's missing is
the fact that, you know,
in Hollywood, you gotta
[laughs] you gotta
spice it up a little bit
to have a storyline. I
get that as a writer, so.
Soldier: Jesus, Dane,
who packed your chute?
It doesn't look good.
Remi: We always check each other's gear.
My platoon chief had a saying:
"Check, check, and recheck."
Yeah, this is a HALO.
Standard HALO. Jumping out.
Soldier: Oh, shit!
Remi: So, what's going on here,
this guy has a malfunction.
Yeah, he's,
this reserve opens pretty late,
probably 'cause he cut away late.
Yeah, it's not that easy. [laughs]
If you have a malfunction
and you've tried to fix it
and it didn't work, you gotta cut away.
And essentially what it is,
you look down, and you
look down at that red tab,
and you pull that cutaway first,
and then you look down at your reserve,
and you pull that away
second, in that order.
There have been people who've died,
not just in the military
but in civilian jumping
because they had a malfunction
and they made it worse by opening
their reserve parachute
before cutting away,
and their reserve
parachute now gets tangled
in their main parachute, and, I mean,
it's nothing you can do after that.
I have to give it a,
I'd have to give it a five, man. [laughs]
I have to give it a five.
[gunshots]
Soldier: Echo 02, moving to deck three.
[gunshot]
Remi: First and foremost,
they're operating at night.
Every, this is a DA. It's a direct action.
They're going after a specific target.
I've done a lot of these,
and 99% of them have been at night.
I think I heard three shots initially,
and then he shot him again
while he was on the ground.
People say, well, that's excessive.
We do that for a reason. 'Cause, you know,
it's not like in the movies.
In the movies, you shoot
a guy one time, he falls.
In reality, you know, you can shoot a guy
six, seven, eight times,
and he can still fight, so.
See, they're really silent.
It's just hand squeezes,
and there's no verbal communication.
I mean, it was a mirror image of
a lot of operations I've been on,
as far as, like, the movements
and the tactics and sneaking through.
Those lasers that you
see, we can see them,
because of the type of
camera that was used.
But we use IR lasers on our weapons.
Typically, in some movies,
you'll see the red lasers
or green lasers on guns.
That's super unrealistic.
We use hand signals or, you know,
or we use our weapons
as a way to communicate with each other
so that we can stay stealth
and stay completely silent
and not tip off the enemy.
Soldier: Clear.
[woman grunts]
No vests.
All clear.
Remi: When they came across the women,
the first thing that they did
was they searched them,
and they were searching
them for a suicide vest.
The enemy will put suicide
vests on women and children.
I remember when there was
a guy we were tracking
for a long period of time,
and I won't mention
the country we were in,
where he would recruit, you know,
kids 9, 8, 7, 11, 12, 13,
and put suicide vests on them.
Rating for this one, this
scene, this specific scene,
because of the way they moved tactically,
I would give it a 9.5.
Waters: I'd just like to
hear what you guys have to say about it.
That's all. Speak freely.
Lake: My opinion, sir,
we cut our losses.
This isn't our war.
Remi: That is one of my
favorite Navy SEAL movies.
I'll say that.
I'll say that first and foremost.
It was directed by a phenomenal director
by the name of Antoine Fuqua.
It really shows the
interaction between SEALs,
but not just, not just
SEALs, but, you know,
the leadership of a SEAL platoon
and the other guys, the
sled dogs, so to speak.
We have a saying, again,
"Leadership at every level."
And so we all are able to give our input.
I've been in situations with my OIC,
OIC's officer in charge of the platoon,
and where he wants everybody's input,
he wants to hear, "Hey,
how should we take down,
how should we take down this
target? What should we do?"
And it's not like other military units
where you just had, you
got one guy in charge,
and, you know, he says,
"Go storm that mountain,"
and everybody just mindlessly
goes and storms that mountain.
Interestingly, a lot of
people don't know this,
but the requirements academically
to get in SEAL training
are really, really high.
And a lot of guys who do show up
to the SEAL training, BUD/S,
they have bachelor's degrees.
A lot of them have master's degrees.
There were guys who were established.
I mean, there were guys
who were accountants
and lawyers or big businessmen,
and one day they woke up and said,
"You know what? This is boring.
I wanna be a Navy SEAL." [laughs]
Yeah. You know, that scene,
I would give it a 9.5.
It's hard for me to give anything a 10,
but, yeah, for that
scene, absolutely a 9.5.
[gunshots]
[screams]
[explosion]
Not only these guys covering and moving,
but they had proper 360 security,
which allowed that one SEAL
to see that suicide bomber.
As soon as they took contact,
they immediately started firing back.
And that's something that we always do.
We, you know, suppress the threat.
And then, yeah, again,
we have 360 security.
So, the contact was in the front,
and, you know, again, SEALs
are not mindless robots.
So everybody didn't just start shooting
at the contact in the front.
If somebody gets injured
in the field, you know,
first and foremost, if they
can take care of themselves,
they take care of themselves
in the middle of the battle.
And then once somebody can get to them,
then that person, you know,
goes and gets them and tends to them.
In the Navy, we don't call medics, medics.
We call them corpsmen.
And once that corpsman can get to them
after the threat has been
suppressed at that point,
then they'll go tend to them.
Eric: Bravo 6, say again your last.
Ray: 6 to base, I say again. Fallen eagle.
Remi: When somebody gets
killed on operation,
you know, you win the fight,
and then after you win
the fight, you know,
you help, you know, transport,
transport them back to base
and give them a proper ceremony.
Soldier: We lost Bravo 1.
Eric: How long till we
can get him out of there?
Remi: I would give that
scene specifically a 9.5.
Commander: I need sights on targets.
I need three targets green.
Remi: Passing comms to the snipers
who are gonna take the target
so they're aware of what's going on.
Again, going back to communication.
Communication's key.
Commander: Stop the tow.
Execute.
[gunshots]
Phillips: What was that?
Remi: He could have been a commander.
Commander's actually a rank,
but for the sake of just
explaining this point,
you know, we had a commander
who was definitely a Navy SEAL,
and he's giving commands,
but he's also giving the guys,
you know, giving the guys
freedom to do their job.
He's not micromanaging them.
And so throughout that scene,
there was a lot of great communication.
And that's 9.5.
9.5 is like a 10.
I have to say 9.5 because, you know,
Hollywood has to spice things up
and dramatize things, so, I get that, so.
But, you know, for me, I
would say that was a 9.5.